لماذا هناك من ينجح في عمله وهناك من يفشل
هناك من يتقدم وهناك من يبقى في مكانه على
كل حال لا تعتمد الحياه المهنيه على
الشهاده الجامعيه فحسب في العمل وعلى دروب
النجاح قصه اخرى تبدو والحياه المهنيه
اصعب دوما الامن الامر يكون اكثر تنافسيه
مع الاخرين في سبيل النجاح الوظيفي هذا
النجاح يلخصه موقع لينك ان في عده خطوات
وطبعا التقدم الوظيفي والتقدير العمليه
يرتبطان بقوه بالاستعداد والرغبه في
الاداء الجيده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
موقع المشهور انه اشهر موقع للتوظيف او
للتوظيف طيب
للنجاح الوظيفي والمهني ما رايك
خلينا نلخص ال 10 نقاط بثلاثه اركان
الاساسيه كلها تندرج تحت الاولى اسمها
بادر بما تحب وتتقن الثاني اسمها خذ
الموافقه قبل ان تبدا والثالثه اسمها
تواصل بذكاء عامه عشان ندمج الافكار كلها
اللي طلعت حتى من مقولات ستيف جاف ذو
مقولات الناس وغيرهم خلينا نرجع نلاقيها
كلها في بدايه البرنامج
ما استنى احد يجيء يطلب مني بدري بما تحب
ليش تحب الاثنين لازم تكون موجوده تحب
لانه في اشياء انا احب اسويها وفي اشياء
انا اذا انت تتقن الشيء وانت ما تحبه
هتقول انا خليني اتقن هذا الموضوع انا
اساعدكم فيه طب تعال ساعات انا في ممتاز
خليك فيه طب انا احبه
قادر بحاجه انت ما انت حابه دائما ابحث عن
اللي تحبه النقطه الثانيه هي انه كيف ممكن
اخذ الموافقه قبل ان ابدا ليش اخذ
الموافقه قبل ان ابدا بسببين بسبب الاول
انك لو تيجي تبدا بمبادره معينه وانت ما
اخذت موافقه مثيره اولا هنشوف انك ممكن
تخطيته ويبدا يصير العامل النفسي يقول لك
لو سمحت وقف من قال في الموضوع هذا لا
تخلي الناس تحس بالغيره او المنافسه معك
خليهم يحسوا انك انت بتساعدهم انهم يكونوا
افضل انك انت اللي شخص اللي بتنتجه وتبقى
هم كلهم يرتفعوا معه في نقطه جدا هذا زي
ما قلنا المبادره بما تحب
يعني لا تقضوا ما لا تستطيع لما كل شويه
تقول لهم انا مبادره اعطوني اعطوني اعطوني
ما راح تنجز في نهايه تراها يعذروك لو ما
انجزت هيجوا يحسبوك ليش قلت تبغى تسوي هذه
ما سويتها ليش ما انجزتها يبدا يصير
الموضوع يسموه باك فاير عليك انه انت جالس
تبادل باشياء رجعت عليك وسيره الانسان
الغير المنجس